tonight's lecture Emmanuel petit is well
known to many of us in the
probably all of us associate professor
of architecture he holds the Diploma in
architecture from the h aha Switzerland
we're studying under Mario compy
Vittorio Lappin Yanni and course
Forrester after completing his studies
in Switzerland professor petit went on
to Princeton where he received a master
of architecture and in 2006 a PhD in
history and theory of architecture with
a thesis on post modern irony professor
fatigue scholarly activities have been
accomplished accompanied by professional
practice he has worked for Eisenman
architects Atelier Jean Nouvel and since
2009 has been in partnership with
release appetit in the firm episteme
architects professor petit was first
introduced to Yale as assistant teacher
in Peter Eisenman advanced studio since
then he is of course joined the faculty
where he offers an undergraduate studio
as well as graduate lecture courses
seminars and studios in 2006 professor
petit organized the symposium Philip
Johnson the constancy of change and
edited the book of the same title
published by the yale university press
in 2009 he has published articles and
important scholarly journals and we look
forward to the publication in 2012 by
the yale university press of his book
irony or the self-critical opacity of
postmodern architecture based on his
Princeton thesis although he's available
for second title choices if you want is
everyone
many have you visited the exhibition and
architects legacy James sterling
students at Yale 1959 to 1983 that
Professor party curated last fall as
part of yellow Yale celebration of that
distinguished British architect now it
is our privilege to enjoy the exhibition
of sandwich I grauman's work in our
gallery curated by Professor petit who
will elaborate on his work in that
exhibition in his lecture scaffolds of
heaven on tiger minh please join me in
welcoming emmanuel
this is not supposed to be the funny
part yet and I have a bunch of people to
thank and I will do that first I thank
Dean stone of course for having me here
for involving me in this and for giving
me the mic it's a little bit risky but
here I am I want to thank Stanley
tigerman for just being the cool guy he
is I learned a lot from him and he makes
me think I want to thank David Reinhardt
who assisted me in in curating the
exhibition upstairs he was instrumental
for this I thank Dean Sakamoto Brian
Butterfield Linda Fisher Jessica Swenson
Nina Rappaport Karen Carter Lynch table
Wayne Mara Wilhelm Melanie taleen
Margaret Margaret McCurry Laura Tatum
and Michelle call me so lots of people
involved in getting an exhibition up I
would try to conceptualize what I think
Stanley tiger men attempts to do with
architecture he himself wouldn't mind
being portrayed as a sort of free
thinker and even libertine of the
architectural discipline while
paradoxically constructing himself as
the defender of ethics in architecture
he is somebody who insists that what
architects do with physical architecture
is important but that ultimately the
architecture of the here and now is a
mere scaffold to support ideas that
exceed by far the sphere of art that lie
beyond the expressive possibilities of
architecture the study field of
philosophy has institutionalized a
series of major figures the positive
philosophers who constitute the
foundation of the field as we have come
to define it Plato Kant Hegel and the
like you know them but it also drew its
vitality from their dialectic
counterpart
the anti philosophers Socrates
Kierkegaard but I those thinkers who
don't play by the rules and who some
would claim have no business being
counted as part of the discipline of
philosophy however they appeared so
indispensable in making philosophy move
if given the choice tiger men would
certainly side with the anti
philosophers constructing himself as a
sort of anti architect who cannot leave
the discipline because it is what fuels
his resistance the resistance to all
these fantasies of perfection synthesis
and performance of do Buddhism in the
world insist that he wanted to become an
architect when he read Ayn Rand's
Fountainhead it made him furious if you
hope is to save the world built the
largest shelter shelter for homeless
people like Stanley did with his Pacific
garden mission in Chicago it just opened
four years ago or found a school for
socially responsible and environmentally
conscious design like Stanley did with
Eva Maddox when they found it our key
works in 1994 but do not expect an
invitation to the architectural Hall of
Fame for it for that you need other
techniques our intellectual disciplines
do not work that way you need a theory
of anti architecture Stanley has also
provided something of that sort before I
start my talk really I should say that
never before did I feel my European asst
as much as I did when confronted with
Stanley's American asst and a brief
anecdote will help earlier this year as
we were sitting in his office in Chicago
lunchtime was approaching when Stanley
took charge of the difficult task of
composing and ordering the perfect meal
for me with the typical cheeky smirk on
his face he ordained you will have a
jelly peanut butter white bread sandwich
and he added I need to turn you into an
American because Bob Stern will do it
anyways the way I would structure my
talk is by taking you on a series of
walks through one of tiger men's cartoon
drawings one of his architects the
largest one from 1983 which he entitled
Korea collage it's the first wrong you
see when you enter the gallery upstairs
for my use it doesn't really matter that
this is by now a historic document from
the heyday of post the post modernism
discussion I think it still lays out
most of the central ideas tigerman is
interested in although some of these
ideas took on new forms and new
structural realities in the quarter
century following the Korea collage and
I will show those to this lithograph can
be seen in the tradition of surrealism
with a lowercase s an example being here
only Mo's Bosch hear his Garden of
Earthly Delights triptych not so
different from tyga' means drawing
bashas canvas is this imaginary world
populated and animated by strange
objects and grotesque creatures engaging
in sinful pleasure the painting is built
on visual metaphors and puns it is full
of sexual connotations relating mythical
and religious idealist narratives to
certain customs and also taboos of the
social life at the time it is his
rendering of paradise on earth this is
what happens to paradise once it becomes
grounded in the here and now painting is
amusing meaning the realism of Paradise
has comic effects as it points out some
of society's ethic traditions and moral
vices taga means Korea collage is not so
different in narrative and compositional
character it is also nested in
natural earthly context under the clouds
and the Sun on the earth and water in
between Hills not somewhere up there in
heaven but with tiger men his dream
world turns autobiographical in the
drawing tigerman reflects about his
place in the history of architectural
ideas at the time he entered the field
this was precisely what would get you in
which could create a link to the field
didn't Philip Johnson publish his seven
crutches of modern architecture in 1954
where he claimed we have very
fortunately the work of our spiritual
fathers to build on we hate them as all
spiritual sons hate their spiritual
fathers but we can't ignore them no can
we deny their greatness the man of
course I that I refer to well to grope
us look obj Mies van der Rohe a Frank
Lloyd Wright i might add the greatest
architect of the 19th century Tyga Mets
history is bracketed by on the one hand
Greek architecture to suggest ancient
history he seems to have taken a piece
of architecture from Sicily and on the
other hand the largest big project of
the den dean of the school of the Yale
School of Architecture sees appellee's
World Financial Center in New York this
project would only start construction
two years after Tyga means drawing it
denotes the present as it unfolds at
that time so you have ancient history on
the one hand and the present and the
construction on the other the two
snapshots from the historical timeline
set the stage for the history tigerman
wants to connect to and inscribed his
work in with Tyga mean however histories
related to the life cycle of himself as
an individual who moves at his own pace
through a series of experiences and
discoveries ultimately that year of
history is never really perceived as
liberating also for him but illustrates
the difficulty of breaking loose from
the chains of influence of the canonical
precedents the self reflective view of
history was theorized by harold bloom as
you know well in his 1973 book the
anxiety of influence which is a very
convincing description of the Cree
if procedure of that generation of
authors and artists in it bloom claims
that the young power gains freedom by
willingly miss reading the poetry of the
antecedent it was also I dare say a way
to justify a serious dose of narcissism
that every guy had to be proud of as
such it is Tiger man himself who likes
to point out the unmistakable influences
to be found in his work in the early
work at least among these one will find
in the decades following the graduation
from Yale in 61 did the influence of
Paul Rudolph here in one of the houses
tagamet designed right after graduation
it's the chapman house from 1963 with
its exposed brick and concrete tough
appearance and brutalist appearance the
play with the multiple levels of the
floors and ceilings the expressive
spouts and chimney all those things that
Rudolph himself put to use like you can
see here on the top in his drawing for
the Christian Science Center at the
University of Illinois a project
tiger-man obviously knew or here is an
example of an office building by tiger
men from a series of typology studies
tigerman bid for advertisements for
insulated masonry walls also from the
early 1960s and it's not hard to see the
brutalism that most directly relates to
the building we are in tonight one also
sees the influence in the polytechnic
institutes which were commissioned by
the World Bank trying to develop the
technological know-how in what was then
West Pakistan what would become
Bangladesh in the liberation war in 1971
not only the architecture but also the
drawing technique of course clearly
borrow from Rudolph this is the site
plan of one of the five Institute's as
well as the plan of one of the staff
housing complexes for these five
projects throughout Bangladesh tiger men
collaborated with a former classmate a
Yale classmate bhusawal Islam it was
Islam who brought tiger men but also
Rudolph and Louie Cohn
Bangladesh as part of the so-called
American trio so this is how calm got
the commission of the Dhaka assembly
hall Khan himself of course is another
knowledge influence his early studies
for the Polytechnic Institute show cants
characteristic round openings in the
heavy masonry walls you also see a
detailed study of one of these openings
when they slightly changed shape but
they are reminiscent of Khan's Assembly
Building in Dhaka as well and by the way
away Islam also worked on that dagger
project for calm or bombs housing in
1966 the homeless shelter and a slightly
more domesticated version of the
aesthetic fiegerman appropriates from
calm the Kalma arlington industrial
building evokes carlyon tropes but it
converts the archetypal primitiveness of
con circular openings into a language
meaning a witty game of fragmentary
forms how circles quarter circle circles
that are sliced in two by columns that
change their meaning depending on the
composition of context they get inserted
in unlike on the circular openings are
there for the graphic effect they
produce and unlike con circles columns
and doors establish a self-referential
formal language this is from the early
70s oh it's a slightly later project and
no doubt by the time by this time robert
venturi had an impact on tiger man's
thinking and also charles more with his
super graphics now then there are those
inferences that hagaman doesn't mention
as much what does it like to mention
because he didn't have the same
appreciation for them among them jim
sterling who he did not like and who had
just started to teach at Yale it's not
funny yet
had just started to teach at Yale when
Tiger man was here style sterling had
just constructed the construction at at
Leicester this is tagged immense sand
Benedict's Abbey Church in Wisconsin and
you can see how on top sterling and
gowans camberwell Assembly Hall might
very well have acted as a guide for the
spatial pinwheel typology the tiger man
uses and in this search for what kind of
architect argaman was going to be the
interest in the structuralist
architecture in structuralist
architecture should not go unmentioned
notably photog event series of projects
entitled instant city this one from the
mid 60s urban matrix instant football
the kingdom of Atlantis they are all
these bold steel and glass structures at
a very big scale some of them floating
on the water this is an architectural
expression of optimism and of the
confidence in the power of architecture
to impinge on the socio-political
relationships of the real world only a
few years after these projects tigerman
would revise his faith in this
optimistic attitude around the disasters
of the Vietnam War I will come back to
that while these structures might very
well be some of his spatially most
powerful projects he could never
reconcile their utopian ideals with his
own skeptical attitude in that sense
they were mannerist as they mimic an
attitude of his contemporaries among
them kenzo Tongi of course is
metabolized Tokyo Bay project now below
is tagged a man's urban matrix this
regular grid of inverted pyramids built
over Lake Michigan it's mostly
residential urban matrix was connected
to the shore by cables which could be
clipped in the event of a nuclear attack
so that Chicago's inhabitants could
float away I guess to Canada it's very
1960s in spirits and a bit
tongue-in-cheek as well or your honor
Friedman's space city from the
nineteen fifties early sixties Friedman
proposed a framework that is raised
above the ground the natural ground and
water a sort of carpet hovering covering
the natural ground which is again not
unlike tiger men this is a perspective
of tiger man's instant football with its
completely symmetrical plan it's a
residential perimeter by the football
field a kind of kannada to the central
importance of popular culture in the
states we build pyramids too but they
are not for the Pharaoh but they are for
football at a monumental scale here
abstractly placed in the landscape again
the 60s were full of these projects
Bucky fuller designed his tetrahedral
city for 1 million people in 1967 it was
first published in Playboy so by the new
newer issue the ship cova couple in
Russia envisioned this autonomous
pyramidal residents for 2,000 people in
Siberia and the swiss architect used to
star hinden published his urban
structures for the future in 1971 a book
tigerman refers to die hindman designed
a slightly more domesticated version
himself of a pyramidal pyramidal
building along the lake of zurich the
so-called feral house built in nineteen
seventy while for most of these
architects the scientific findings of
system analysis theory network theory
cybernetics and field theory largely
contributed to their interest in
devising these large architectural frame
frame works for herbalife to unfold for
tiger men the primordial question
remained one of artistic composition
indeed in the context of these projects
tigerman reference references were yogi
capers the RTA theorist who taught in
different institutions in Chicago not
least in the new Bauhaus at IIT or
Robert slutsky and Colin row and their
hypothesis in the mid-to-late 1950s of
the phenomenal transparency of certain
figures meaning the optical quality that
is able to index certain complexities in
the deep space of architecture but on a
flat surface then Mondrian and the
notion of the non-hierarchical field of
the canvas and of course and importantly
josef albers who had it yields
department of akkad until nineteen
fifty-eight tiger men became fascinated
with Elvis's compositional experiments
that evoked spatial constructions and so
the projects I just showed you were
accompanied by a whole series of
abstract studies in pictorial
composition on the left is a conceptual
axon for Tiger man scaled another plant
this project which I am comparing by the
way that is the that is a resort project
that he got paid for so it's not it's
not like a utopian do it yourself in
your basement kind of project he got
paid for that project and it's a good
for a resort that you know now existing
in a Cell Atlantis the resort so on the
left is a conceptual exon photog immense
kingdom of Atlantis project which I am
comparing to Elvis's canvas shrine which
deals with very similar with the in a
very similar way with the transparency
of overlapping figures in space both
play on the paradox of the notion of
transparent lines in quotation marks a
type of transparency which of course can
only be conceptually nature not and not
phenomenal lines cannot be transparent
in that in that sense alberta's
composition often involve the
geometrical play with the diagonal and
the lozenge compositional
characteristics that tigerman
transferred right into his paintings his
diagrams and ultimately his architecture
here is one of taiga men's formal
generators of structure next to
albertsons canvas from the kinetic
series these generators of structure had
many iterations and acquired more
complexity as they evolved they are
based on diagonal displacements as if
prospectively penetrating the center of
their compositions they would then take
on spatial and structural qualities that
are not so far removed from the
architecture I just showed you
and again another iteration in fact
there were 78 of these iterations total
during this period tiger-man also
created oil on wood paintings they
emerged from the visual dialectic
between orthogonal grid systems and the
45 degree rotation as we saw with his
architecture now these have the long
manifesto like title if you turn the
canvas you see the title I pledge
allegiance to the lozenge and to the
implications for which it stands this
title certainly announces tiger-man
xyron extends towards the strict rules
and the aesthetic straitjacket of his
late modernist training with its
uncompromising geometric program and its
almost mystical color theory for him it
was like pledging allegiance to the flag
indeed Stanley makes clear that this
serious matter is to be regarded with
some skepticism however a skepticism
which will later determine his work here
you just get a hint in the title among
the influences of precedents Tiger man
likes to invoke one reference is given a
particularly vital and dramatic role
with this particular antecedent argument
relativize is the general optimism which
he saw as endemic to the discipline
relative izes it with this own sense of
skepticism and that is Ludwig Mies van
der Rohe mies became tigerman stro
figure almost the voodoo doll that had
to take all the blame for all the things
tiger-man objected to in modern
architectural culture this leads me to
the second story I want to extract from
the career collage if you zoom in on one
particular constellation of buildings
next to the water you will realize it is
mrs. federal center in Chicago which we
started working on in 1959 when Tiger
man came to Yale and was only completed
posthumously in 1974 it is one of Mises
abstract and monumental downtown
projects with the homogenizing tinted
glass curtain wall facades for which he
was by that time
so well known now tiger men most is
building into giant extruded crosses and
thus converts mises abstract building
masses that had no apparent
architectural rhetoric into symbols
certainly the symbols of Mises death in
1969 but also symbols of the disturbing
fact that while the man had died his
acolytes continued to perpetuate an
aesthetic that they turned into a cliche
for the global export and left me
Zionism in Tiger man's mind purged of
its initial poetry purged of its
liveliness nice had turned into the
dominant corporate architectural
paradigm and hence Tyga man found mrs.
architecture had been diminished the
post medians had become the power
players of Chicago and in this sketch
from the 1990s by Tyga man you can
identify them by name some teach here in
a letter to meas in 1978 when Miss had
already been dead for nine years Tiger
man wrote you'll be in Yumi's you'll be
interested to know that lots of nice
buildings are now being designed for
Arabs so this is relating to the
question of the global export and then
he talks about the Chicago context the
illinois institute of technology is the
same as it was ten years ago the
architecture school is still the same
old Jesuit seminary then forget means
was a German Catholic tigerman a Jew so
the IIT is still the same old Jesuit
seminary seminary it was when you were
here and they still import seminarians
from the Black Forest for graduate
school who still believe in your cradle
built don't talk tiger-man insisted that
buildings have narratives that they do
talk that they do carry the memory of
the architectural discipline the history
of a place and the stories the architect
wants to convey in the Korea collage
tiger-man put one of his own buildings
right next to mrs. it's the Pensacola
building it is an attempt to bring back
an architectural iconography which
museum ISM had suppress
and that can give identity to Chicago
the courtyard the townhouse facades two
columns capitals ornamentations etc that
give he claims I don't want to end
identify too much with that he claims
character to this place on the yellow
trace drawing above you see the unfolded
facades with townhouse silhouettes and
clouds i might add surrounding a
courtyard like a town square and in the
rendering you see how the rowhouse
iconography appears on top of the plinth
these houses here and then you see the
column applique and the corn is in the
facade of the main building now
Pensacola was to reintroduce memory into
a pragmatic city without memory with
this in mind in his reinterpretation of
the site plan for the graceland cemetery
which I find a more interesting because
more perverse project Tyga mean adjusts
the geometry of Chicago to a line his
and his office partner and wife Margaret
McCurry's common tomb with an axis
connecting meeses gravestone and also
Louis Sullivan's with Lake Michigan and
with Tiger man's Pensacola and boardwalk
buildings so just like his view of
history tagamet interpretation of the
place of Chicago turns autobiographical
here indeed how much more graphic can
you get about tracing your lineage in
both historical time but also in a city
plan then to align your own future tomb
with nieces and bending your hometowns
geography to fit this scenario it's a
graphic illustration of blooms anxiety
of influence if you zoom in you see the
annotations the permanent resting home
of Louis Sullivan and miss van der Rohe
and then a block of excuse my French
then Pensacola and answer one here is a
phone model of the two tombstones for
Stanley and for Margaret it's two
self-similar cubes but rotated in two
different directions according to the
privileged orientation
of Stanley and Margaret's respective
Jewish and Christian faith I think Peter
Eisenman should get royalties for this
one after the deaths of nice
architecture had to be reanimated in new
ways for tiger men this meant that the
formal system of orthogonal grids and
precise and rigid alignments of axes had
to be supplemented with something else a
new energy and other geometry and other
s ethics and this is the process whereby
Tiger man finds his role as an architect
you see that around this time his
architecture starts to move away from
all these precedents for example here is
a townhouse for Chicago that clearly has
references to modern architecture as
such the car is given a very prominent
place in the scheme remember how low
Cobra he had put cars in front of his
villas in many of his photos also the
scheme is abstract it does not reference
any encoded architectural rhetoric but
the architecture is modern nevertheless
but with a twist it is more involuted
than mrs. gridded houses it closes its
corners then demonstratively by rounding
them off in the sense in a sense the
house is n time ease and brings back the
notion of the architectural object as
opposed to the field nice of course
mostly opened up the corners to make the
interior space of the houses participate
in what the German aesthetic theorist I
wish massive had called there alone the
universal space for of course universal
men but here are some of the coziness of
the individual house as a psychological
entity is back for tiger men it was not
simply about doing away with nice but it
was about relative rising the sole
validity of the museum paradigm in 1978
tagamet created the now famous collage
entitled the Titanic where he made crown
hall at IIT float in a precarious
position in Lake Michigan both the
semi-transparent water and its waves and
perpetually changing forms of clouds in
the sky in the background are no
light motifs of psychoanalysis in this
collage mrs. architecture is setting
dialog with all the things me said to
suppress to maintain the crystalline
appearance of his structures to make the
structure universal as opposed to
individual or even personal but Tiger
men wanted to show that something was
lurking under the surface of mrs.
rational superstructure and his
positivist certainties that would go
that that could now after mrs. death
crop up from their repressed state a new
power structure existed in architecture
culture in in Chicago and Tiger man
wanted also to see its new aesthetic
emerge by 1978 to turn to psychoanalysis
to re-energize the discourse of late
modernism was not completely novel in
architecture madelyn reason dog in
particular had painted a series of
canvases in them at the early to mid 70s
which addressed the hidden subconscious
layers of in her case pragmatic
Manhattan amongst them Freud unlimited
which I'm showing here and which shows
the rational Manhattan grid as a mere
thin blanket on the bed of the island a
mere blanket that covers a potentially
exciting why should say delirious I
guess exciting delirious but chaotic
underworld the unconscious
infrastructure of the city in addition
the Empire State Building floats in the
water in much the same way as the
Titanic in entitlements collage in
reason tops canvases to water and clouds
take on the role of GMA of geometries
dialectic other now the ideas expressed
in Prague immense Titanic actually
influenced his architecture and I think
that is really a moment that is crucial
in taiga means thinking that moment when
with the labadie house in nineteen 76
and 77 tie them and set nieces
orthogonality in dialogue with a more
fluid geometry a wave-like geometry it
is as if mrs. grids were supplemented
with the curvilinear
pretty of waves and clouds to produce
the convoluted play plan of his house
which by the way sits on the shores of a
lake concept he is supplemented with the
chaotic phenomenology of natural shapes
here is the labadee house next to mrs.
Tobin tart house and I wanted to show
these side by side because nice of
course does use how circular walls
himself but always as discrete objects
inserted in an orthogonal field but
never as continuous wavy lines which
constitute the field like Tiger man does
now it is also evident that these
drawings have some form of resemblance
with with the work of Tiger man's friend
John hey Doc whose work had experienced
a similar transition from an abstract
and geometric face to a more lyrical one
at much the same time throughout the
1970s their work is extremely similar
but I want to point out the fundamental
formal difference between tiger men and
hey Doc you will notice that tag immense
wave reforms are always based on a
series of how circle of arcs of a circle
which I indeed derivative of Mises half
circles whereas headaches curves come
from Corbeau who derives the curve from
the Cubist guitar the piano shape and
other lyrical curves this is a local bee
gees bull his tahoe 18 from 1960 and
ecology himself used the curves as you
know well in his architecture like here
in the carpenter center from 1962 and
you see that the curve is much more
composite less geometrically singular
than it would be in the entire man Tyga
means wavy lines tend to be rational and
hey ducks more lyrical that is because
one comes out of me the other one of
code of Cobra here the wiggle in the
labadee house appears in all kinds of
different constellations through many of
arguments projects each of these
projects plays with the geometric credo
of modernism in one way or another I say
play because he doesn't simply abandon
it altogether but doesn't accept it at
face value either taga man was asked to
do an addition for a house designed by
George Fred Keck
who was the architect who had designed
the house of tomorrow for the Century of
Progress exhibition in 1933 was himself
influenced by mies and also marcel
breuer kak also did the crystal house in
1934 both of these projects made him
into the pioneer of passive solar houses
as a positivist modernists keck saw in
technology of course the innovative
force for architecture notice the
aircraft that's parked next to the house
in this rendering of the crystal house
this is part of KX fantasy that
individual mobility will go high-tech in
the near future tiger-man sedition
illustrates again the merger of modern
tropes and endless space with other
types of geometry of the curve vagabond
doesn't borrow directly from KX
high-tech aesthetic though but instead
builds on his own version of a built his
own version of a passive solar house in
quotation marks based on the formal
logic of a wiggly line composed of half
circles but this time in elevational
section not in plan the addition has
this complex glass roof now what is
crucial is that the technical equipment
which for a modernist like kak was the
very foundation of the renewal of
architecture becomes subservient to tie
them as forms which is to say that the
air ducts for ventilation is here and
the electric cables and light fixtures
follow the glass roof contour meaning
the form of the building tagum interns
text technical utopianism into a sort of
formal mannerism again the building
looks like a machine but it is not clear
what this machine has been designed to
do no longer form follows function but
air conditioning follows form these
houses of tagum and i just showed you
are all from the late 1970s and they are
from a time when the discussion about
post-modernism was about to reach its
apotheosis no doubt the notion of foam
acquired a more and more central
importance in architectural culture at
the time and this is also the case with
stanley so let's have a look at these
forms around at that time here is his
house with a pompadour
for a client who wore his hair Elvis
style so the house gets its own Pompidou
a gable marking the entrance to the
house in the field of the get the gable
panel plaquemine cuts out the triangular
opening which index is of course the
shape of a classical pediment without
however having having it do any of the
tectonic work of a pediment it's a sort
of inverted pediment the negative
pediment the sign of a pediment these
forms are strictly allegorical they
reference culturally coded images let me
go back to the career collage many of
the shapes in the Korea collage appear
like extruded silhouettes you will find
tigerman represent houses where the
outline of the front facade is simply
elongated into deep space he also does
this with graphic and typographic
science here they are which reads
disease and you heard Stanley claimed
last week that architecture was a
transmittable disease which is of course
part and parcel of his optimistic social
agenda in architecture that architecture
can really contaminate people to
participate in creating our environment
but he also excludes sometimes the
silhouettes of trees sometimes clouds
etc now form is here directly derived
from 2d graphic outlines the resulting
forms are not really is
three-dimensional but they are
two-dimensional signs turned sick and
for we simplify to the point where it
becomes immediately legible each form is
a simple silhouette just a vignette in
his built work this idea produced things
like this this is a car garage for the
Illinois regional library for the blind
and the physically handicapped in
Chicago it allows near blind people to
understand the form as they only see the
silhouette in a sense the building fits
the content like a glove fits the hand
it's a parody of the form follows
function paradigm
but it's technique is also borrowed from
the world of cartoons here is a cartoon
I found in The New Yorker a drawing
which illustrates well the idea of the
graphic sign value of objects I like
best the couch that resembles a cloud
that acts as a kind of negative pediment
very much like the ones the one I showed
you in tagum ins house with a pompadour
Tyga man himself is an extremely
prolific cartoonist and as such at the
time he aligned himself with the other
so-called postmodern architects for whom
cartoons represented a rich source of
inspiration among these John hey Doc
robert venturi charles mujer Bob Stern
michael graves and others in the States
and in Europe Ettore Sottsass han Solo
and Gustav pie shell among many others
this is hey Dex project for the
international building exhibition in
berlin-kreuzberg in 1987 the wing
buildings have only one facade here is
the facade and then they are simply
extruded this operation is analogous to
stanleys so one side of the building
alludes to the archetype of the
vernacular house the face of the house
allegorical while the other elevation
elevations are the result of the
modernist and formalist process so again
the house is modern but with a critique
attached to it let me also give you a
European example Gustav pie shell who
was himself a prolific cartoonist for
magazines and newspapers also
occasionally at least derived his
architecture from the graphic nature of
his caricatures and capitalized on the
silhouettes of simple 2d shapes this is
a stage that he designed for the Pope's
visit in Vienna in the early 1980s and
with light satire of course paisa
borrows the shape of a cloud to frame
the Pope's appearance on the mega-screen
and he shows the the helicopter with the
Pope arriving to the scene these
buildings find the origin in the
tradition of actually take you up a
glance around the French Revolution
think of Culloden
do and if you prefer the trickier
version of this idea take generic liquor
now I get to the adults-only version of
my lecture or part of my lecture not all
forms are equal when it comes to
conveying an allegorical sine value they
do famously designed is akeem our
building for the initiation of young men
and the mejor de plaisir emo matter and
base them on a phallus shaped plan
locker found the same shape intriguing
and used it to devise a sort of altar or
monuments to celebrate the omnipotence
of God omnipotent of God the fallacy
appears in elevation and section now if
you look at the Korea collage again you
will find this building it is Tiger
man's Daisy house from 1975 278 now the
project combines tragedy with comedy the
client was a terminally ill cancer
patient and the owner of strip joints in
Chicago Parman decided to base the house
plans on a hermaphrodite w con Agra via
female and male genitalia in the face of
the approaching death of the client
Tiger Tiger man wanted to make him laugh
so the Jana's face scheme has a dividing
wall a bit like hey Doc small houses on
one side of the world the plan is
fellows shaped why the beach side of the
wall relates to the female anatomy this
tablet structure provides for a main and
a female elevation you will notice that
is Whitney reinterpretation of venturi
venturus decorated sheds has a Spanish
missionary bell on top of the female
elevation I let you guess what this one
stands for here is an explanation of the
architectural party and indeed you will
see that Stanley explicitly refers to
LeDoux and liquor and adds a fictitious
name the dick
what is most interesting is that the
diagram makes clear that the party has a
built-in logic for future extension
here is the house as it was built and
just noticed the facade materiality
these vertical planks that make a smooth
curve possible there is no doubt that
Claire's oldenborg acts as an influence
here not only with regards to the humor
of the plan shape but also in relation
to the tectonic realization this is
Oldenburg's mouse museum which precedes
the Daisy house the facade is very
similar and you can get you can see that
one enters all in books pavilion in much
the same way than one enters the Daisy
house through the curvilinear extension
which in all the box case is Mickey
Mouse's tongue stuck out here is one of
Alton box models which was on display at
the Museum of Contemporary Art in
Chicago in 1977 now what to make of
these references to the con Agra fee of
the let's call it the lower stratum of
the body and I think I think this is
really central it's not only a joke it's
really central to what stanley tries to
do and i hope to be able to say why now
Sigmund Freud of course helps in these
situations here's a sketch by him and
titled what is on a man's mind it's an
order portrait and according to him
sexual jokes the Daisy house being one
of them our way of letting letting out
sexual repressions of course typically
Freud right when human sexuality merged
the genre of burlesque is at play so the
Daisy house is an architectural is
architectural burlesque but Freud also
describes these jokes as a way to
express a critique against an
overpowering authority and that I found
really interesting so here we go again
with the topic of rebellion against the
hegemony we are faced with an attempt
tiger man's attempt to liberate himself
from well that is the question in fact
from a bureaucratic positivist overly
regulated and pragmatic socio-cultural
context from which he wanted to distance
himself as a sort of cultural libertine
he often mentions the problematic moral
stance
that got the united states involved in
the vietnam war for him this was an
expression of a broken ethical
orientation underlying the american
society at the whole as a whole and
surely he was sensitive to this kind of
thematic as a jew who was well aware of
what was going on in germany when he was
a teenager I think the best account of
the meaning of tag events created
response to this cultural malaise is to
be found in a book that came out in
Germany in 1983 the same year as the
Korea collage and that is Pettis Lhota
dykes critique a cynical reason I won't
elaborate too much on this I don't want
to be accused of bad taste by our Dean
but i just want to point out that in the
book slow today establishes a list of
what he calls the psychosomatics of the
cynical zeitgeist so this is from the
table of content and you can see this
the physiognomy instruments of this type
of satirical critique that's lot alike
identifies you see tongue stuck out
mouth smiling maliciously Crockett
lalala I I gazes breasts as it's far
[ __ ] genitals this could be a taxonomy
of all the elements we find in tag
immense cartoons slaughtered like
explains the truth often speaks against
convention conventions and the satirist
maybe Tyga men plays the role of a
moralist who makes it clear that one has
to violate morality in order to save it
slotted I continues it is necessary to
rethink the usefulness of the unuseful
the productivity of the unproductive
philosophically speaking to unlock the
positivity of the negative slaughter
dykes comment resonates well with tiger
men tiger men who insists that the
different expressions of idealism in
architecture the value of permanence of
synthesis of perfection and so
have limited architecture to a very and
growing Lee narrow and abstract medium
of expression so for Stanley the
burlesque might not be the solution but
it points out the problem here our stand
his buildings going about their business
of a postmodern orgy these are the hot
dog house in the Daisy house from rocky
Thun and for the 1976 biennale in Venice
Stanley printed the dirty postcards to
distribute in the in the exhibition hall
again here in he was joined by other
architects in this kind of critique who
mobilized the same genre of set theory
criticism hey dukh from architectures in
love or hotline this is Holland's view
of the meaning of Chicago skyscrapers
and of course Sottsass all of these
expressions were directed against
obedience against being part of the
hegemony against belonging to a program
or manifesto in the way the modern a
Vegard had it in its place came the idea
of freedom of individualism of breaking
out of the chains of all discipline and
of the system but it's an unhappy
freedom it is well known that tiger men
created the group of the Chicago seven
in 1976 the architectural homologue of
the political Chicago seven around Abbie
Hoffman Jerry Rubin lean Lee winner and
the others who rioted in Chicago in 1968
in protest of President President
Johnson's vietnam war policies kagamine
created the architectural Chicago seven
to affirm an alternative to the
officially sanctioned traditions of
chicago architecture the well rehearsed
histories out of his Sullivan Frank
Lloyd Wright Daniel Burnham and the
usual names you know well but this lose
constellation of people of the Chicago
seven was also meant to put Chicago on
the map after the East Coast had seen
the whites and the Grays appear and the
group of LA architects emerged as the
silvers now the east and what
close groups had teamed up around common
agendas and they were very clear the
whites were interested in the economy of
foam the gray saw themselves as
inclusive ists and the silvers gathered
around specific concerns of technology
and other mobility but the Chicago seven
had no such program if anything they had
a negative program they defined
themselves in the negative they knew
what they were not going to do Tyga man
claimed that the Chicago seven i quote
have nothing to do with each other
formally and now personally I don't even
see them it was the only way we could
get seven desperate people who had
nothing in common including respect for
the other but one thing we had in common
we needed to penetrate a city that was
monolithic that was me Xion the program
of the Chicago seven was not really
artistic since there was no real agenda
but more existentialist in character it
was about survival and the sort of
freemasonry thinking in a context where
the big forces were in place and where
and and were not up to letting and
letting any newcomers in one of the
Chicago sevens projects was to invite a
series of individuals to submit late
entries in 1982 an architectural
competition which had taken place in
1922 the Chicago Tribune competition
well the gropius and other losses
buildings were two of the products that
became icons of the competition six
decades later many of the the late
entries commented on these modern icons
but with a sense of infantilism Fred
cutter bending gropers his building as
if the building had been hit in the
stomach if if you don't want or don't
manage to kill the father at least you
have to humiliate him reveal his
weaknesses and Livesey and Rosenstein
bringing back the lost innocence of
chicago architecture as they claim
themselves after it has been taken over
by big business
this one also explicitly referred again
to claes oldenburg these were further
attempts to signal the desire to escape
from the aesthetic straitjacket of the
big system of modern architecture in
spirit they are analogous to tag immense
Titanic I'm returning to the career
collage and I will extract just one more
scene from it it is a group of buildings
along the shore with chimneys on top of
them with steam coming out and little
dogs flying vertically up into the sky
and with train tracks entering the
buildings the reference to the Nazi
concentration camps is obvious Nazism
was a historical example of a perfectly
organized machine that had puts it put
its ideological agenda before common
sense humanist and ethical concerns it
is in the complex of tagum and
self-understanding as a Jew that he
declared in his book verses in 1982 that
post-modernism is a Jewish movement in
1988 he further elaborated on this idea
in another book entitled the
architecture of exile now the idea I
want to illustrate is already well
documented on the two book covers cover
images vs. shows a tombstone that is
cracked in two halves and the rift
separates the profane world of reason
and sin and analysis from the spiritual
and sacred sphere of faith and the
search for synthesis despite the attempt
of angels and soldiers on either side of
the stone to bring both these opposites
together the crack persists and the
stone resists unifying and RM synthesis
analogously the cover of the
architecture of Exile on the cover of
that book a double cube illustrates
stanley's version of an architecture
that as a physical object can never
pretend to be complete in and of itself
the sketch explains that the realm of
ideas the metaphysical reflections and
interpretations always escort the
physical object of architecture
architecture is not simply present but
it's ideas are in exile moving freely
and unstoppably through the labyrinthian
dynamism of architectural discourse the
architecture can the architect can plan
the geometry of the building but he or
she can has to resist the conceit of
determining how a building is going to
perform out there once it has been
inserted into real space and time in
1992 tiger and wrote the text entitled
to contain contaminants of architecture
with reference to the imperatives of the
ten crack commandments no doubt but also
with illusion to Philip Johnson seven
crutches of architecture as the title
already suggests target tiger-man
posited that architects obsession with
purity bead formal ethical or
ideological had drained the discipline
of its vitality this is ultimately what
Tiger man is after architecture will not
be eternally perfect as the ideas about
perfection are changing with the
dialectics of history the notion of
perfection is always dynamic this
realization is fundamental to any
ethical philosophy emmanuel levinas and
martin buber being two of Stanley's
favorites if you suppress the voice of
an other by simply blossom over all
difference with an aesthetic of
perfection and of course he thought
modernism did exactly that in all its
facets where nothing an aesthetic of
perfection when nothing is out of place
where nothing can be added or subtracted
as Albert II had already fantasized you
disconnect from the dialogue with other
people and Tiger man was not willing to
do that the metaphor of the scaffolding
week I became the truest expression for
tiger men of the hiss of the process of
historical dialectic in architecture
scaffoldings are temporary and they
marked the existence of a building which
is about to be erected or to be taken
down scaffoldings are
perfect but they indicate an energy of
transformation the express vitality they
express life well architecture cannot
help but aspire to ideas of perfection
and synthesis the classical ideas of
photog a man all architecture from
hellenic hellenic beginnings to modern
architecture the ethical post-holocaust
and post-vietnam architect as he likes
to call himself has to be more self
conscious about what is being glossed
over in this search for synthesis
tiger-man indicates his repeated
skepticism by slicing through the
classical symmetry and emptying out its
core to be filled with new movement a
new production of contemporary memory
this is especially true with the
Illinois Holocaust Museum and education
center where light and darkness are not
synthesized but coexist as a sort of
double temple to be experienced he
indicates that architecture is based on
two fundamentally different building
materials in quotation marks one is
man-made and the other one is natural so
this one is is a conventional building
materials and this one is out of trees
sir and both building materials appear
in balance and in dialogue half the
building is constructed with nature so
to speak the second volume of the
building is composed of trees to simply
build on top of nature to dominate
nature and that is also part of the
ethical agenda will make the Titanic
sink indeed if the death of ideas is not
out of the architects consciousness
history will sooner or later remind him
or her of the notion of finitude and
death it happened to me here his flooded
Farnsworth House and it happened to Luke
obg this one pointed out by burner to me
in one of his famous advertisements for
architecture in 1975 we're truly claimed
that the most architectural thing about
villa savoir is the state of decay in
which it is Jimmy's idea was derived
from georges bataille and the connection
that i seen as saw between eroticism
death on necrophilia in the book Greek
versus Hebrew by theologist o life
Bowman tagum and found his view of
dialectics articulated in the most
convincing way in a nutshell Bowman
attributed to search for presence and
clarity to Greek culture Hebrew culture
in contra distinction built its
metaphysics on the notion of absence of
memory of just remembering the home that
one is in exile from one is never in
possession of the home this Hebrew
culture in bham its description is about
rereading and reinterpreting the text
that explains why Stanley said
post-modernism is a Jewish movement it's
about rereading about letting inserting
architecture into the dialectics of
history photog amend the translation
into architecture was most direct the
Greek Acropolis and is the paradigm for
all architecture architecture is built
on the APIs team of the Acropolis and it
builds on presence and clear form and it
even physically still exists you can go
and look at it and bang your head
against it laureus world and all the
other were her fantasies derive derive
from this intellectual APIs team but
there exists another were hurt that has
always been merely peripheral a
peripheral paradigm for architecture it
is the Hebrew temple the Temple of
Solomon which was destroyed and so its
existence is not physical it doesn't
exist anymore but it is only narrative
and speculative it exists as a memory
parga man proposes that architecture can
be enriched if we accept that physical
buildings are mere placeholders mere
scaffolds the whole universe of ideas
which we can think but never really
realize what you see is only a vague
diseases offices for my office
a little bit photoshopped or back then
not photoshopped just collage what you
see is only a vague approximation of
what you can imagine of what you can
dream in that sense architecture is
profoundly surreal thank
family isn't here to your but i'll send
a copy to it oh my god i hope there are
some questions for Emanuel I know he's
counting on them Ava lisa has a question
yes thank you for the great talk I am I
was thinking about the 22 of first
images that you showed the two very
recent projects and your comment about
them I think one was a homeless shelter
and other one was can't remember and
achey works yeah I wonder how would you
like after now this hearing your talk
how would you fit those projects into
the trajectory well I I think what would
what I'm trying to say is that there is
an activity that people do that doesn't
make it into the Hall of Fame and there
are other strategies that get you a
place in the Hall of Fame that make you
relate to the discipline as it has been
constructed so I'm not making any
essentially claim about what disciplines
ought to be but in in the way our
intellectual institutions work to just
build a homeless shelter and it doesn't
do it and so what you need and that's
strategic you needed to construct a
discourse and I think Stanley did that
exactly that and but I don't want to
diminish that discourse I I mean I'm
very aware of the fact that for instance
the construction of the whites was the
greater surgical services the syllabus
is kind of a you know we generations
will rehearse the same story and
that's it brings its own problems with
it Stanley was very aware of the fact
how that historical process will play
out and he used it to great effect and
but again I want to say that that has a
function that has a function because it
allows us to understand a certain type
of criticism in architecture and it has
a value but that's that's slightly
different from doing a homeless shelter
for homeless people take another example
REM koolhaas it's very effective in
doing buildings that do whatever they do
in the real world out there but he's
very careful about constructing this
course that gets him into into gets him
into the discourse of architecture and
it's very careful about about
constructing that and Stanley is too but
again it has a function I don't want to
diminish that I just want to make make
it very clear that that is what happened
what is happening that answer your
question anyways I'm so yeah ever that
answer your question i had the field you
have the mic give it back I just that I
mean I get that but I was wondering
about what you know is it you know it
what role do they also have for him is
it like he sold out you know is it just
the dream is over you know what's going
on no no i don't i don't think it's
selling out at all i mean if anything
that ultimately that shows you that that
Stanley is not merely playing with all
of our heads but that he is actually
serious about his ethical project that
there was a real component to it and and
that that he means it and so for me
that's not selling out at all and you
you might have you might remember that
last week that was one of the projects
that he showed and I i just sat then I
thought well this doesn't have much of a
polemical content this building it just
doesn't whereas the Daisy house is kind
of crafted towards making certain claims
about
about the culture of architecture and is
just more effective for for what we do
in this context but for me I mean that
homeless shelter and I visited it with
him and he was very entertaining when I
drove his car and we were supposed to
park and there was a barrier and the guy
who was supposed to open that and and
Stanley told me well when we get close
open the window and tell the guy to go
in himself and I saw the world that
that's a weird way of talking so we get
close to the barrier and I opened the
window and here comes the guy and says
oh mr. Tiger man welcome back he knew
everybody in that homeless shelter
everybody he walked through that
building and was greeted by everybody
and so clearly while he is a master of
playing these what I would call in the
intellectual institution of architecture
on the one hand he is actually serious
about about an ethical agenda out there
there's a question up there sir building
off of what Ava or what you've mentioned
and get into the Hall of Fame I think
you've done a wonderful job of sort of
showing us and telling us about you know
convincing us that Stanley is certainly
a man who's got ideas that are worth
considering and very thoughtful ones but
I wonder if you could speak about the
fact that they're probably not ideas and
thoughts and polemics have been much
considered in the past 40 years well not
40 sorry maybe 30 years compared to
maybe many of his peers are you asking
what his legacy is a would be your poor
well I mean perhaps he was quite in the
picture and in the conversation very
actively in that in the discourse but it
seems I would argue that perhaps he's
not been so much in the past 30 years
could be a question of why Stanley
diagramming now which is a
question to ask well I'd I mean I didn't
I didn't take the career collage from
nineteen eighty-three by coincidence I
think that was a very potent moment for
Stanley and and it's it's not like
everybody needs a new idea every day I I
think that the the ideas about ethics
that that Stanley is still very
interested in were already establish
back then they were there and they just
moved and took on different forms and I
think his is one of his latest buildings
the the Holocaust Museum in Chicago or
in skokie is it's not a building i like
i should say but that's not the issue
here it is it is a building that that
it's almost the the project he has been
waiting for it it deals with all these
issues of religious ideas meeting the
problems of the here and now he brings
in the idea of the cracked the crack
volume the double temple I mean all
these these ideas are in fact played out
in a in a new way in the sense that is
its aesthetics is very ivanova now it's
very modern in the sense of contemporary
it's a the inside of the building is is
industrial very cold not so bad at all
but i think that the seams they they go
back a long time and I think 70 82 83 is
where it all comes to comes forth as a
project
other questions oh right I'm curious is
part of what you're saying about Salomon
that the dialogue is that architecture
is a polemic a dialogue between cultural
ethical surreal aspects and that the
physical genetic kinesthetic aspect of
it is secondary at this time in his for
him in our culture well that problem of
the distance between the physical thing
and the metaphysical idea is something
that fascinates me and I think that
architecture is always confront
confronted with that problem you know
how how do ideas and things how do they
connect to one another and I i guess the
time and the project if you can describe
it that I'm describing here with tiger
men and is very interested in making
clear that these distance exists that
that things are not ideas but they are
things and in a way Tiger man can make
funny buildings because he wants to mark
the idea that it is not about the
building that the building is merely an
index of something that lies beyond that
is greater that in fact you you cannot
you cannot build in the material world
so it's a very very in that sense even
idealist although he would hate to hear
that that maybe not with a capital I but
an idealist approach to architecture
that that architecture has these
physical markers that stand out there in
the rain markers of what architecture is
about but that they are near indexes of
ideas that lie beyond hence the title
the scaffolds of heaven that I chose for
my for my talk that scaffold are
scaffolds they they just they just
reference a building that you don't see
but you can imagine it and it's the
imagination and the dynamics of that
imagination that
is rich for architecture that makes it
really rich and we are in a very
different moment today I would say it
that is not one of the problems that
architecture the architecture discussion
is really interested in now if anything
it is about collapsing that difference
it is about saying you know screw you
with your theory show me the thing that
make it perform maybe make it a phone
that's that's where we add at the moment
that's absolutely not what tiger men was
about and and that is also not what nice
was about so Stanley and many many other
architects of his generation and take on
also that historical role of that is a
critical role probably because of that
distance that in between me and what we
do now Emmanuel you're starting to
suggest something that I've been
thinking since Stanley's lecture the
other night during which by the way he
said remarkably little about the are key
works project and and all of that and
and it plays into something that you
seem to be starting to frame so I'll
throw it back at you and see what you do
with it and that is that that in a very
important way what you're calling
cynicism and what I would maybe call
cartoon strip metaphysics is all an
elaborate form of dissimulation that is
is is hiding partially hiding an almost
deep embarrassment about how profoundly
serious Stanley can be at times not so
much about architecture but about the
things that you just mentioned lying
beyond or behind architecture and and so
you know when I think of you started
with bataille and with the negative
philosophers or the anti philosophers
and I wonder at the end of the day if
that's not really the company that
Stanley keeps
except when it suits him so just in a
nutshell it seems to me that what's
starting to emerge is a sense that that
kind of world-weary cynicism I've seen
it all I know at all the ability to
manipulate images promiscuous Lee the
kind of cartoon aspect of the the car
tuning of the ideas is at the end of the
day a way of not dissociating but more
de simulating the the dead seriousness
of the project well and I want to be
clear that I didn't call him a cynic and
and slow the dike makes that difference
between a cynic and and the satirist I
didn't use the word that he uses because
it's so complicated ack unique the
satirist i would call him a satirist in
the sense that yeah he he does play with
with humorist imagery to make clear look
what you are looking at is merely merely
an index to make you think of something
else and he is absolutely serious about
that something else i mean if you if you
look at the text that we printed on the
columns in the exhibition upstairs you
you will you will I mean it's good
enough to to see these words taken from
the Bible and you will think whoo how do
we get from architecture to the Bible
well that's exactly that's that's the
paradox that architecture has to be so
ridiculous sometimes so that what
architecture is about can be deadly
serious I just want to say that i never
think you know I've known him forever
it's not a cynical person I know the
service is deadly serious I wasn't using
its citizens
they're one of these strategies along
with her tuning along with mannerism
along with his remarkable and facile
ability to riff on anybody at anything
that floats over the surface of this
other project I would I would never call
him a cynic I would call REM koolhaas a
cynic yes and and and it's very close in
the kind of strategies that he uses
absolutely a cynic for the reason the
difference is that kool haus doesn't
have that kind of idealist program that
that that sits behind that that gloss of
satire and of pagado no and whereas with
Tiger man no no he wouldn't be because
it's it's just it just signifies that
modernity has moved on to its new more
crazy stage and Tyga mean never does
that agree so weird there's a question
up on the balcony thanks you gave us a
very good sense of the some of the
influences on tiger men or and the
things to which he was reacting would
you find it as easy to put your finger
on what Tiger man's influences on others
have been like other disciples of tiger
men is there a school of thought that it
is picked up on his thought either cub
well I am not sure if there is a guy who
teaching the teachers in this school who
called me yesterday and he said well so
good but does the stem you have a
project not that guy that guy um well
maybe to even ask that question is
already part and parcel of how we expect
our intellectual institutions to
function meaning you know cut the
[ __ ] give me the 23 points that I
can you give me the five points of tiger
men and we'll make something cooler out
of them I am i I don't I don't think
that's how this type of work works I
think when you announce your theory as a
theory of the the contingent of the in
India of the particular it is very
difficult to suddenly pretend that you
can make a new school out of that and so
my answer would be I I don't know
because his teaching isn't the kind of
teaching that moves in these big ways
you know meas grid Cobras a five points
that that's not how Tiger man Tiger
man's project was then a lowercase P
works it's in it had it has its function
its cultural function and also its
disciplinary function I don't think you
can you can reduce him to clear
teachings that now move on but satire
has moved on and I and we we have new
generations of satirical people who by
the way become mana wrists of the
previous satirists I find that very
problematic I think samet argument does
a project called cut through
the crowd always cutting through the
pretensions of the profession which he
sees with the very clear I and that
makes you not he is always the most
popular person but always very respected
and feared a little bit but his purse I
feel that his contribution is not the
buildings or say as a manual sub really
points out what the fact of them and how
they have to be seen as mirrors of the
times in which family has 50 years
practiced architecture so I think
cutting through the crap isn't a bad
thing underfoot I don't want to have the
last word you I gave that to you the
martinis shouldn't get hot so we should
go upstairs